Vice President Mike Pence joined us
earlier this morning in studio 57 for a
wide-ranging interview during a break we
asked him about the new effort by
senators Graham and Cassidy to repeal
Obamacare and the status of pre-existing
conditions do you support a plan that
could allow insurers to charge more
premiums for people who have
pre-existing conditions or who are
elderly the president's made very clear
that there were elements of health care
reform that we wanted to preserve
including protections of pre-existing
conditions and as as a senator Cassidy
and Senator grandma made clear their
legislation does just that but look we
have a very clear choice
before the American people whether we're
going to stay on the path of the failed
and collapsing policies of Obamacare
that have seen premiums rise choices
decline millions of Americans have lost
their coverage have lost their doctors
or whether we're going to going to
embrace the idea of state-based
innovation and reform what the Graham
Cassidy bill does and the president and
I strongly supported it essentially
repeals the individual mandate so
Americans can choose whether they buy
insurance or not again it repeals the
business mandate but then it block
grants the resources to the states so
that that 50 different states can
innovate the way I did when I was
governor of the state of Indiana just to
put a finer point on that you are right
it does continue to protect people with
pre-existing conditions however it does
allow waivers to insurers in states to
make the decision about where they want
to charge people more who have
pre-existing conditions or charge the
elderly more would that be fair is that
right but nor the the the whole concept
of Graham cassadee is built on the
American principle of federalism it's
the idea of allowing 50 different states
to innovate and create new ideas and new
products that will better serve all of
their citizens by block granting
resources to the states instead of
creating a one-size-fits-all program in
Washington DC will have will have some
states that will go one direction some
states that will go another direction
but people will be able to see as we did
in Indiana but each kind of reforms that
will improve access to health insurance
coverage lower the cost of health
insurance and ultimately improve
people's lives but even with federalism
are you prepared to give States the
right to waive a pre-existing condition
clause the president's made it very
clear that we stand by his commitment to
protect pre-existing conditions but at
the end of the day that we just have a
very clear choice about a week ago
Bernie Sanders and a number of Democrats
in the Congress laid out their ultimate
vision for health care and that is
single-payer health care driven out of
Washington DC and what what Graham
Cassidy articulates is a completely
different direction moving power out of
Washington DC empowering states to do
what we did in the state of Indiana when
I was governor we actually introduced
health savings accounts into Medicaid we
got people to move from the emergency
room to primary care we had some
underprivileged Hoosiers through the
first time ever were able to choose
their own doctor and and have their own
fund to be able to pay those first
expenses out of so there's lots of
innovation that can happen as I said the
president I truly believe in federalism
and state-based innovation and reform
and the momentum that you see behind
this bill 15 different governor's coming
out in favor of the bill I think will
only continue to grow in the days ahead
your vice president your staff is
turning purple so I think you have to go
yeah you have another engagement thank
you very much you don't want purple
statement no you don't not healthy thank
you very much